[Music]
being here at farnborough leaves me a
little bit conflicted
i've always been a huge admirer of human
ingenuity and inventiveness it's
enriched and improved our lives in so
many ways but when it comes to making
aviation truly sustainable and climate
friendly i wonder if it's met its match
but this is a start
it's a battery driven air taxi capable
of taking four passengers about 100
miles so not really denting bulk
passenger transport
i know it's a bit of a cliche but it is
very james bondi
it is british built and has some high
profile admirers who'll soon have more
time for a getaway the government has
just published updated plans to end the
climate impact of aviation with a
promise to never let the sector's
emissions exceed 2019 levels and make
domestic flight net zero by
2040. it's called jet zero hello prime
minister tom heap from sky are we going
fast enough towards low carbonation jet
zero is going very well but but we we
can always go faster
looking around the show it's clear that
reality is well behind rhetoric
this is the only zero emission plane
that could carry me over britain today
[Music]
i've got to clear my leg
past the joystick that's it
this is comfy well it's nice we got a
standard instrument paddle with with a
six-pack i'm tempted to slide shocks
away
when it comes to getting the big beast's
airborne in a climate-friendly way we've
barely got off the ground
when you look out of these can you tell
which ones have got rolls-royce engines
with them well well they'll be big ones
time to talk to the boss of one of the
big engine makers warren is sustainable
aviation really a contradiction in terms
it's like sort of dry water or virginal
pregnancy
it's uh it's certainly not that much of
a contradiction in terms in fact it's
it's our raison d'etre at the moment is
uh to ensure that society can benefit
from all the benefits that flying has
bought for the last 100 years
but ensure that we can do it in a way
that doesn't cook the planet in future
warren says that powering big planes
like this on zero carbon fuels like
electricity or hydrogen is unlikely for
20 years so the current suggestion is to
make liquid hydrocarbon fuel not from
oil but either from plants that would be
biofuel or synthetically from captured
co2 and green hydrogen
these are known somewhat optimistically
as sustainable aviation fuels
if i want to buy some sustainable
aviation fuel today the chances are the
source of carbon is a biofuel of some
kind the real answer isn't bio because
um we won't have the scale we're we're
not really solving the problem you're
running into issues of biodiversity and
all of those sorts of you certainly i'm
the land take to supply biofuel for
aviation is extraordinary that's why
it's not sustainable i think it's imp it
has a role to play as a as a sort of
small transition uh because we have to
get the sort of biofuel ecosystems up
and running to then
eventually move over to synthetic we
haven't got the land for biofuels for
aircraft no no we haven't and that's why
you need to do direct carbon capture
uh and
green hydrogen production to put the
synthetic aviation fuel together that's
the only way we're going to get scale
without running into the biodiversity
challenges direct air capture and green
hydrogen are technologies in their
infancy and they're very expensive are
people going to have to pay more for
climate climate-friendly flight surely
that's inevitable ultimately
if if people want to continue to enjoy
the benefits of aviation
and
do it in a carbon-free way there's
there's going to be an increase in cost
the aviation business prides itself on
achieving what was once thought to be
impossible
it gets these things to fly after all
but with current technology connecting
the planet without cooking it looks a
little pie in the sky